STAY OUT OF TROUBLE TONIGHT.
VEGAS IS A DANGEROUS TOWN.
ALL RIGHT, HERE WITH
REACTION.
"FOX & FRIENDS WEEKEND"
CO-HOST PETE HEGSETH.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR JASON
CHAFFETZ.
TEXAS CONGRESSMAN LOUIE
GOHMERT.
WE’LL START WITH YOU
TONIGHT, JASON, I’M WATCHING
FARMER MIKE.
>> I MEAN, HIS COMMENTS ON
RACE.
HEYOU JUST PUT A SEED IN THE
GROUND AND COVER IT WITH
DIRT AND PUT WATER ON IT.
I’M LIKE WOW, CAN YOU BE
THAT IGNORANT?
IS IT POSSIBLE TO BE THAT
STUPID AND SAY OH,
FARMERRERS DON’T HAVE GRAY
MATTER?
>> I ACTUALLY LIKED WHAT
DEVIN NUNES SAID.
DEVIN IS AN ACTUAL FARMER.
I HAVE BEEN TO HIS HOUSE.
I HAVE SEEN THE FARM.
I HAVE SEEN HOW THEIR FAMILY
MAKES A LIVING.
I HAVE GOT TO TELL YOU WHEN
HE COMPARED MAYOR BLOOMBERG
TO SOMEBODY WHO THINKS THAT
YOU JUST BUY A CHIA PET AND
POUR WATER ON IT AND THINGS
GROW.
THAT GUY THINKS HE IS GOING
TO BE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES BUT HE IS
GOING TO FINALLY GET
CHALLENGED AND I DON’T THINK
HE CAN PULL IT OFF.
HE IS NOT UP TO THIS, SEAN.
>> Sean: CONGRESSMAN
GOHMERT, WE HAVE FARMER MIKE
SAYING THAT MURDERERS AND
MURDER VICTIMS FIT TWO, NOT
ONE M.O., TAKE A
DESCRIPTION, XEROX IT, PASS
IT OUT TO THE COPS.
ALL MALE, MINORITIES, 16 TO
25.
AND THEN PEOPLE SAY TO ME
SO, YOU KNOW, YOU ARE
ARRESTING KIDS FOR MARIJUANA
AND THEY ARE ALL MINORITIES.
HE SAYS YEAH, THAT’S TRUE.
ALL MINORITIES.
WHY?
BECAUSE THAT’S WHERE ALL THE
CRIME IS.
AND THAT’S WHERE WE PUT ALL
THE COPS.
ONLY --
>> Sean: I LIVE IN NEW YORK.
LOUIE, I CAN TELL YOU THAT
IS AN ABSOLUTE LIE.
>> YEAH.
AND THAT IS ALSO EXTREMELY
RACIST.
AND IT’S INCREDIBLE THAT HE
HAS GOTTEN AWAY WITH IT AS
LONG AS HE HAS.
BUT, YOU LOOK AT THE
JEALOUSY AND THE BIGOTRY
THAT IS GOING ON IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
I MEAN, HAVE YOU GOT BERNIE,
HE IS SO UPSET WITH THE
BILLIONAIRE, IT’S GOT TO BE
BANK ACCOUNT ENVY BECAUSE HE
IS ONLY A MILLIONAIRE AS A
SOCIALIST.
YOU KNOW, I LOVE THE
BOLECEVIC BERNIE THAT YOU
USED.
THE PROBLEM WITH SOCIALISM
IS NOT ECONOMIC.
IS ATHEISM.
BECAUSE ONCE YOU MOVE INTO
SOCIALISM, IT BECOMES THE
GOD.
AND THERE IS A SMALL LITTLE
RULING CLASS AT THE TOP AND
THEN EVERYBODY ELSE.
BUT I ALSO, BUTTIGIEG, HE
REMINDED ME OF THE STORY
JESUS GAVE US ABOUT THE GOOD
SAMARITAN.
REMEMBER, THE GOOD SAMARITAN
SAW THE GUY, HAD BEEN BEAT
UP.
BRUTALIZED SO HE RAN BACK TO
THE SAN HE DERON AND THE
GOVERNOR AND SAID YOU HAVE
GOT TO PUT A TAX ON
EVERYBODY ELSE SO WE CAN GO
TAKE CARE OF THIS GUY AND WE
NEED TO TAKE EVERYBODY
ELSE’S HEALTHCARE AWAY SO WE
CAN TAKE CARE OF THIS GUY IN
THE DITCH WHO DIED WHILE
BACK THERE TRYING TO GET
TAXES ON EVERYBODY.
THAT’S NOT WHAT JESUS TALKED
ABOUT OBVIOUSLY BEING
SARCASTIC.
SO, OBVIOUSLY, HE HAS GOT A
LOT TO LEARN ABOUT
CHRISTIANITY.
APPARENTLY HE IS STILL ON
THE MILK PART, HASN’T GOTTEN
TO THE REAL MEAT.
>> Sean: LET ME GO TO PETE
HEGSETH.
JUST IMAGINE THIS WAS DONALD
TRUMP SAYING THESE RACIAL
COMMENTS.
FOR ALL THE FAMED OUTRAGE
WITH EVERYTHING WITH DONALD
TRUMP AND WOMEN, WOW, I
CAN’T REPEAT THE STUFF THAT
WE NOW KNOW ABOUT BLOOMBERG
THAT HAS BEEN REPORTED EVEN
BY "THE WASHINGTON POST."
I GUESS THEY WERE FORCED
INTO IT.
BUT, THE REALITY IS, WHAT?
THIS IS HOW THEY REALLY
THINK?
>> YES, EXACTLY.
IF DONALD TRUMP SAID A
FRACTION OF WHAT MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG SAID, HE WOULD BE
PUSHING GRANDMA OFF THE
CLIFF.
WELL, THEY ALREADY CALL HIM
A RACIST.
BUT THESE ARE OUTRIGHT
RACIST REMARKS.
HERE’S THE THING THOUGH.
I THINK WHAT WE FOUND IS A
THIRD SIMILARITY BETWEEN
BLOOMBERG AND TRUMP.
THEY ARE BOTH FROM NEW YORK.
THEY ARE BOTH BILLIONAIRES.
HERE’S THE REALITY.
THEY BOTH SPEAK A TRUTH.
NOW DONALD TRUMP’S TRUTH WAS
HE IS SAYING OUT LOUD WHAT
THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN
WERE WHISPERING FOR YEARS AS
SOLD US DOWN THE RIVER.
HE YELLED WHAT WE WERE
THINKING.
A GUT TELLER SCREAM OF
MIDDLE AMERICA.
MIKE BLOOMBERG IS WHISPERING
THE TRUTH OF THE ELITES.
THIS IS WHAT THEY TRULY
THINK ABOUT MIDDLE AMERICA,
ABOUT THE DEBLOCIALS.
ABOUTDEPLORABLES.
PEOPLE WHO WORK HARD FOR A
LIVING.
HE MADE THE MISTAKE SAYING
IT ON VIDEOTAPE BEFORE HE
HAD NATIONAL AMBITIONS AND
CHANGING HIS PARTY YET AGAIN
AND EXPOSES HIM FOR WHO HE
IS.
THAT’S WHY DONALD TRUMP WON
AND MIKE BLOOMBERG CAN’T
WIN.
WE NOW KNOW WHO HE REALLY
IS.
>> Sean: WHO WILL THIS
RESONATE THE WILL THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA MOB
GO AFTER ALL OF THE THINGS
HE SAID ABOUT MINORITIES AND
WOMEN AND FARMERS?
I MEAN, I’M SHOCKED IF THEY
DO.
>>
>> I WOULD BE SHOCKED TOO.
I’M NOT GOING TO COUNT ON
THE NATIONAL MEDIA TO DO ANY
OF THIS.
BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
SMART.
THEY SNIFF THIS STUFF OUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT WINS
ELECTIONS?
IT’S AUTHENTICITY.
IT’S A PLAN FOR AMERICA.
AND IT’S THE ENERGY.
DONALD TRUMP BRINGS ALL
THREE OF THOSE TO THE TABLE.
THAT’S WHY HE DESTROYED THE
REPUBLICAN FIELD.
AND WON THE NOMINATION AND
ULTIMATELY THE PRESIDENCY.
DESPITE ALL THE NATIONAL
MEDIA.
BUT, AMERICA IS SNIFFING
OUT.
THEY ARE STARTING TO FIGURE
OUT THAT THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
BLOOMBERG IS PUTTING INTO
THIS IS ALL A FACADE TO
PROTECT LORD FIRE CHOIR THE
PERSON FROM SHREK WHO ISN’T
WHO HE SAYS HE IS THEY WILL
FIGURE THIS OUT.
THAT’S WHY ELIZABETH WARREN
DOES POORLY.
THAT’S WHY PETE BUTTIGIEG
HAS PEALED BACK THE ONION.
QUITE FRANKLY HOW BERNIE
SANDERS DOES PRETTY GOOD
BECAUSE AT LEAST YOU FEEL
LIKE HE IS AUTHENTIC.
HE DOESN’T HIDE FROM IT.
HE IS A SOCIALIST.
HE IS NOT A DEMOCRAT.
>> Sean: THE MOB IS GOING TO
IGNORE THIS, LOUIE?
>> YEAH.
THEY WILL IGNORE IT.
THEY WILL GO AFTER HIM ABOUT
AS AGGRESSIVELY AS THEY DID
AFTER HILLARY AND BRENNAN
AND CLAPPER AND COMEY AND
McCABE FOR THEIR APPARENT
CRIMES.
WHICH IS NOT AT ALL.
>> THEY WILL WORSE THAN
IGNORE IT.
IF HE BECOMES THE NOMINEE
THEY WILL PARROT IT AND
ADVANCE IT ON HIS BEHALF?